I'm pre cringing for what is about to
happen I've been dreading this video for
the longest time it may come as a
surprise but I didn't always used to be
this hip and cool and trendy no there
were dark days before I did YouTube long
long long ago when my name wasn't
PewDiePie it was just pew die and if you
don't know what I'm talking about
I used to be very active on the anime
forums of my anime list and I've
recently gone access to my old account
from 2007 and we're going to explore it
together here's my profile thank God
most of it has been deleted thank God I
do have 2000 forum posts mmm let's see
what we can find in PT paja oh my god
okay all right what have we got someone
made a thread called there's this girl I
really like and I responded geez stop
posting love prob on these forums way to
help out Felix good job
Warhammer Age of reckoning so this game
was released recently is anyone playing
it I'm installing it at the moment level
6 now XD I'm liking this game already
feels like wow 2 point off I'm playing a
marauder
oh oh oh oh this is painful oh I made
this thread called polar bear defense
itself against raving mad woman
edgy humor what is going to happen to
you after you die Wow what if some
philosophical thoughts I don't mean to
your body but your mind it's hard to
imagine what's going to be like after we
die I'm pretty sure death is going to be
a lot like before we were born I guess
my dream however is that all my
ancestors will be waiting for me in
heaven like it's at the airport the the
early seats of agnostic AZ atheism was
there good good on you Felix
oh god this is painful this is so
painful what do / did you do when you're
bored in class let's see what I said FAP
there's online dating really okay
someone asked and I responded if you
look like [ __ ] something weird about
laughing at jokes that you made [ __ ]
10 years ago what are your thoughts on
incest oh oh no oh oh don't say it don't
say it Felix
don't you mean winces no god damn it god
damn important discussion how how come
as one word when soul and Tsubaki turn
into weapons sometimes they are nude
inside and sometimes they are closed on
I can't I [ __ ] can't man this I
[ __ ] can't do this how do you cool
down after getting angry goosfraba
Adam Sandler references good job oh my
great fan fabulous that is old so nice
what a ha ha moment strange things you
do while or after watching anime fat
stop with the fat what the hell is wrong
with you the taste of the female gender
what character do you hate that everyone
likes why Misa she's awesome
no you don't mean that Felix you don't
mean that
ok you don't meet you don't understand
what you're saying ok Felix no please
this is the worst I can't I can't what
are your dreams I'm in pursuit of
becoming an a renowned graphic designer
well I didn't work out it it
oh this is so strange Mahane a world
without males a world without men would
suck so hard just because then I
wouldn't exist these are like my old
Photoshop holy [ __ ] it's my old
it's my old World of Warcraft character
oh man I was so proud I had the hand of
Ragnar rice Oh about me I'm a pretty shy
guy
Lal I love enemy and Photoshop my
favorite ones are pretty dark
nhk neo Corso gang could soul misspelled
and def No Wow def note is a pretty dark
anime felix so edgy but otherwise i am a
pretty share full guy as you can see
with this picture that i decided to you
[Music]
it's a darker than black oh my god so
what else you can do on this website was
to rate your anime let's see which ones
I rated 10 code guess it's a pretty
[ __ ] good anime Clannad what are you
gay
I mean come on it's 10 out of 10 it's a
good enemy Death Note hell yeah
gang could so hell yeah Mononoke hell
yeah cannon Oh what was that that Moby
oh my god oh that's the one I always
mixed that one up with Clannad cannon is
I think I gave it a 9
you know what masterpiece update cannon
oh my god planets nine planets looks
great that's a great item a I still
agree with most of these ah Full Metal
Panic that was the [ __ ] man butcan oh my
god alright which one did I lay rate the
lowest ha Tyrone Oaxaca oh [ __ ] yeah
it's like a masterpiece movie is this so
depressing I can't stand it it's
supposed to not glorify war and it shows
how bad the Second World War the Second
World War
yeah it shows how bad it is in a
realistic way but man it doesn't made me
feel so [ __ ] that I was like I can't
watch it's like it doesn't it does not
deserve an average review it's an it's
an amazing piece I gave neon genesis
evangelion a 7 the more I think about
this anime the more I love it I would
definitely give it at least an 8 today
maybe a 9 you know what masterpiece
masterpiece it was too young I was too
young and too dumb Love Hina oh my god
god I can't I can't I can't do this
anymore
I have this constant cringe phase on
when I'm doing this this is [ __ ]
goddamn it last ones I updated was I
don't even remember watching these my
favorite character Yagami light hell
yeah it still is show Minami Monta
that's from that game what was he call
[ __ ] I don't remember those Edison oh
it's a lot of math at the time so and he
was like a math freak the character or
whatever so I thought it was cool
is that my email address flex 89 you
know me
flex mister flex 89 what happens if we
search flex flex 89 no no no no no no no
no no no no no no but that the put the
bet
no I say no well I think it's a good
time to end it there thank you guys so
much for watching I'm sure we all have
some embarrassing things from our past
that is now stored online forever and
I'm sure in the future I will look at
the PD PI Channel and just cringe at
everything but you know what you know
what [ __ ] it I'm gonna go and say it yes
i watch anime what are you gonna do
about it
I'm proud god damnit I don't care what
you say I'm proud I watch anime and I'm
proud so if you don't like it you can go
bye thank you for watching this video I
hope me sharing all this was worth it
I'm gonna go and cringe in a corner and
I'll see you guys next time thanks for
leaving it like and subscribing and it's
always squad fan mail